[Music]
first of all I should make one small
note so in my head I misremembered the
title of this talk rather than how to
make the right decision I conceived of
it as how to make better decisions and I
suppose I'd like to kind of work with
that in mind because I think it's a bit
hubristic of me to try to imagine
telling you how to make the right
decision all things considered instead
what I just want to do is kind of call
attention to some of the things that can
go awry when we actually try to make
decisions and kind of bring that to
bring that to your awareness so what I'd
like to do as a way of beginning with
this is first of all I would like you to
begin looking at the first question in
the poll that hopefully you're presented
with which is what factors actually
contribute to making a good decision and
if you can think about possible factors
that contribute to making a good
decision if you can just type in a
couple of one things do some free
association type in what a word or two
that come to mind about factors that
contribute to making a good decision
then what I'd like to do is actually go
about constructing a word cloud based on
your responses and if this is working
hopefully we can actually now start
saying the things that people think
contributes to making a good decision
okay fantastic so now we're beginning to
kind of crowdsource this and so okay so
evidence goals good those are the things
that are coming to most people's
attention and then there are a lot of
other aspects good information intuition
vision and
the alright experience research
fantastic okay so now there are some
things here that I want to already call
attention to you so information in
evidence in intuition those are really
important factors and what I want to do
in this talk is actually concentrate on
some ways in which the evidence and
information that we're presented with
can interact with our intuitions in ways
that seem actually oddly enough
counterintuitive so that way when you
think about how to deal with the
information you're presented if you
aren't careful you can actually end up
making poor decisions or at least not
the right decision in terms of being
able to process that information so if
some of you are familiar with the work
in decision theory or psychology that
people have talked about regarding bias
and these decision issues you may have
seen one or two of the things I'm going
to talk about but I am also going to
talk about some things from experimental
philosophy and from work by persi
diaconis who's a mathematician who
studied coincidences so I hope that
there will be something new here for
absolutely everyone okay now having
thought about what factors make good
decisions let me now turn to the next
item in the poll which is what can get
in the way of making a good decisions
okay here we see responses muddled
thinking emotions in various variables
you haven't tried to control for an
arrow mindset bias seeds and so on fear
clarity okay these are all very good
points and I'm going to come back to
some of these themes as well
particularly clarity because not being
clear about what is the precise question
that's being asked can often lead to
poor decisions okay so with that now let
me turn to the
so let me turn to the next thing the
next aspect of the talk so this is what
I want to cover so I want to begin with
a very brief introduction on decisions
and then look at some areas where our
standard intuitions can go awry and
these will break down into five
different areas and then I want to just
close with some remarks about where you
can go for further reading or further
information on decision making if you're
interested okay so to begin with so I
think one of the things that's really
fascinating about making decisions and
how people have studied making decisions
is that effectively since the very
beginnings of philosophy in the Natural
Sciences the standard conception of
human decision makers has been this
highly idealized perfectly rational
decision maker and so right there I've
got a photograph of the bronze bust of
Minerva the Roman goddess of wisdom art
and commerce and it's this highly
idealized rational agent that's always
been seen as the core of how we think
about decision-making but through the
work of Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky
and a whole host of other people we now
know that there are a whole host of
different kinds of biases and aspects to
our thinking which can get in the way of
how we process information and can
actually lead us astray and how we make
decisions you know both in terms of
conscious bias and statistical bias and
also ways in which our brains can kind
of leap to conclusions
in ways that we are not always aware of
what I want to do now is actually going
to go through and explore some of these
ok so to begin base rate basics let me
begin with a story or just a kind of a
thought experiment
so think about medical testing right
this is going to be a just a kind of a
case study but once I talk through this
hopefully you can see how it'll easily
generalize to a lot of other cases that
you'll be familiar with ok so suppose
that were you're going to the doctor and
you need to take a medical test that is
pretty accurate but of course you know
no test is perfectly accurate
all of the time right so suppose this
medical test for some condition will
mistakenly identify a healthy person as
having the disease 5% of the time but
let's suppose that if this tested least
has the benefit that it will never fail
to identify an unhealthy person okay so
if that's the case now suppose that
we've got a group of 10,000 people and
what do you know about that 10,000
people is that 2 percent of them have
the disease okay so suppose this is just
part of your background knowledge okay
now you go to your doctor they do the
test and then you find out that you get
a positive result now the question I
want to ask is what is the probability
of having the disease given a positive
test result okay so now you can just
think about that for a moment now what's
the probability of having the disease
given a positive test result just think
I mean think about this
okay so what are some people saying so
some people say ninety five percent five
percent two percent two out of seven
okay so what else do people think okay
so depends on the pretest probability
okay it's a good point so in the terms
of the pretest probability you know that
two percent of the population has the
disease the test never incorrectly
identify someone with the disease but it
does incorrectly identify healthy people
five percent of the time that's all the
information you need to know okay
fantastic
so this I think nicely highlights the
thing that can the point about base
rates I think many people have said 90%
of the time ninety-five percent of the
time and so on so I think you might be
surprised okay so this graphic over here
on the right so it's a bunch of dots
don't bother counting them I can promise
you that there are 10,000 dots there one
dot for each person in the population
okay now what we know is that two
percent of the population have the
disease so it's two hundred people we
know that two percent have that and we
know that the test is never wrong so the
test will always identify those people
as having the disease that's where this
little green to rose at the bottom is
about those are the people that the test
gives a positive result for but we know
that everyone who doesn't have the
disease so that is all of the other grey
dots here are healthy but we know that
the test is wrong five percent of the
time for those people so five percent of
those people will get the positive test
result so those are the red dots down
there
so when you say what's the chance that
you've got the disease given a positive
test result what you have to look about
is well how many people is the positive
result correct four versus the total
population who get the positive test
result and that's two hundred divided by
two
200 plus 490 29% so the thing that's
important about this is that in cases
where the base rate the 2% of the
population is very low your intuitions
about what the meaning of a positive
test is can be really quite misleading
[Applause]
you